hey what's going on it's bill burr and
just check it in on you for the Thursday
afternoon Monday morning podcasts that
I'm doing on Friday just to [ __ ] with
all you drug users out there it's pay
day or it's the day after pay did you go
out and blow it and get some [ __ ] a
little bit of blow or whatever so you're
probably breaking my balls saying why am
i a day late and a dollar short I am NOT
a dollar short I'm sitting here in the
all things comedy studio with the one
and only star of last man on earth mr.
Will Forte hello bill how are you sir
I'm doing great it's it's a beyond a
thrill
so I screwed I screwed up the schedule
and and this should have been Thursday
no no no no no not if this is all right
I mean I would have done Thursday if you
weren't on it but people understand that
I'm gonna wait for someone like
absolutely no I'll tell if it was like a
reality show star I'd just be like it's
not gonna work out we're gonna have to
reschedule for another Thursday but uh
no no absolutely man I was psyched I
finally ran into you I've been such a
fan for so long I ran into you at the
night of too many stars yes there was
too many stars there well and I got to
watch you sing the song wanted dead
alive with Bon Jovi that was very
exciting
damn I rushed it oh my god it's just
fresh screaming wanted though crushed in
the bad way
but that was what we were supposed to do
we were supposed to ruin his song now it
wasn't the thing was they didn't want
you to wear the hat because he didn't
want like Richie Sambora to see make it
seem like you're making fun of yeah yeah
yeah I'd say there was some word on that
there was there was a hat that we ended
up not going with it just made me look
even goofier best one of my favorite
things about you is your your facial
expressions I've never seen like the
desperation and like the characters you
do the faces that you make like you like
macGruber or on your new hit show
they're our last last-man-standing like
the looks that you come up with like
it's called the last man on earth not
last man's dance our last man on earth
you know I'm thinking oh my mom does it
my mom
does that did I say that twice every
turn oh you said it you said it right
once and lasts one day I mean as long as
you get last man this is why I don't
this is why I never have guessed what an
[ __ ] I'm gonna write it down so don't
[ __ ] it up last man I just broke a
standing and I had to cross out
basically the last man standing well for
the first couple episodes no spoilers
yeah oh there's gonna be a bunch of
spoilers because I love the show and you
know yeah whatever
shut it off I don't give a [ __ ] it's a
great show and I want to talk about it
because I'm a fan first of all how did
you come you know the look of
desperation that you mentioned is
something that I've basically workshop
my whole life because I've basically
been a kind of a desperate individual
and it's you know the looks come very
naturally to me how so desperate I don't
know just desperate for I'm a little OCD
and and a little a little everything
kind of desperate for do you fix the
first septons okay I would say that's
probably you know I I used to have a
real hard time like leaving a party
unless I knew that I had said goodbye to
everybody
it would took me forever to you know
it's like worrying I don't know I didn't
want people to be offended that I didn't
say goodbye to them or something like
that and then you just learn oh that's
right when somebody else leaves without
saying bye to me and I'm friends with
them I don't think that our friendship
is over
Oh fine I don't know yeah so would you
find yourself laying in bed at 3:00 in
the morning buzz going off [ __ ] I didn't
say I didn't say all right to Mike
yeah yeah and then it would make a
special call the next day hey sorry I
didn't get safe but I'm not joking wait
now where did that what do you think
that came from I don't know probably a
my mom who's a very very nice person and
my sister yeah and you seemed really
like down-to-earth how the hell'd you
end up in this fucked-up business you
just seem like you're you're just like
me I met you with like within two
seconds I'm like this guy's a sweetheart
Oh blushing well I don't know I don't
know you know it's weird because there
are a couple ways into it and a lot of
you know a lot of the the popular theory
is that you know people
work out their aggression and their
their horrible childhood childhoods up
on stage and stuff and mine was a
different different I mean we all got
problems but but mine I have supportive
family I'd agreed was Orville a tough
name growing up it was but I would
always went by will oh you did well
that's not true I went by Billy for like
five years and then I got teased because
of Billie Jean King and so I said I'm a
changed that I came home one day and
just change that to will how why Billie
Jean King we know but just like you know
she was very popular back then I'm 44 so
I was right it was probably 1975 and she
was at the height of her tennis powers
weight you see 119 set when that bite 75
so you're 5 years old and the kids in
your greater like up on the woman's
movement it was a big tennis community
this is Northern California all right it
was you know so did you make you made a
conscious choice to switch from Billie
to will yes because they were they were
calling you Billie Jean King yeah as
nothing yeah yeah that was it it's not
you know all right it's a fact it's not
a great story it's just a Fabio it's
just I find it bizarre the kids at 5
years of age knew who the hell she was
did you know did you hear that [ __ ] was
rigged what was rigged depth I think
Lyndon Bobby Riggs guy was a Bobby Riggs
guy's last name was rig an intentional
pun or was it a pun I don't know what it
was and I'm sure somebody's cringing but
like he wasn't like he could have kicked
her ass and he didn't he'd like bet on
her this is serious well I mean this
could be like people who hate women so
much we're actually creating this theory
on the internet or it actually happened
I hope it happened not out of some slam
and women [ __ ] just out of some
degenerate gambler kind of thing like if
he was like in deep and they were gonna
break his legs or something like that
and I tell you something right now you
whatever the [ __ ] his name is Bobby you
got to lose you got to lose - Billy this
is [ __ ] you were gonna kill you or
something I don't know I I think she
might have beat him ference
she was pretty damn good I mean
I was named after her for like five
years so I've got a stick up for her no
no that section
she should have destroyed him that may
actually bugged me I hand out women
thought that that was like a victory
it's like you went you beat an old man
you had the champion of your sex playing
this old man I mean I mean at some point
I don't bill I'm staying out of this one
you and your God Northern California
guys are just you guys are I guess
really nice people so anyway it is said
I will say that a lot of really nice
people up there it's a it's uh no math
no heroin there's you know there's
probably like it's creeping in
everywhere what did I didn't see a lot
of it I didn't see a lot of meth and
heroin is it when I crazy was meth and
heroin was that just Karen when was over
and meth wasn't around when we were kids
yeah I think I'm actually gonna be doing
a gig in Eureka California really up and
way north oh and I was excited about
that and then somebody you know I don't
know if they'd you never know what the
internet like they just sit there and
they just constantly just go the
negative route on everything but they
were saying that it was a little Shady
am i kind of [ __ ] how could that
place be Shady it's nestled up there in
the redwood forest
I would think people would just be no
yeah even PI's on the windowsill like
well I mean Albuquerque I bet that was
where we made macGruber and and you know
that's obviously where Breaking Bad was
set and so there's presumably a huge
meth situation up there and there are a
lot of great things about Albuquerque so
I think you're gonna find some very very
big positives in Eureka it must be nice
to move a lot of history I Gold Rush
please drive cross-country with you and
I'll just keep going negative you'd be
like you know what I think Oklahoma City
it's gonna have some surprisingly
mom-and-pop kind of places I knew when I
watched your show I was saying to my
wife I go this looks like this this
looks like where they shot Breaking Bad
and I'm so gone I know it's a desert but
for some reason it looked familiar a
little bit some of the landscape and and
she for some reason thought it was like
an Arizona or something so that makes me
feel good we know
last man on earth is but we shoot it in
Chatsworth
but but macGruber was Albuquerque I'm a
group of us yeah yeah yeah how bad am I
[ __ ] this up you are doing great and
I do cross country with you I have to
ask you after you know years of being in
this business and bringing off not even
remotely as crazy and ideas what you
have with that last man on earth like
how the hell did you not only get that
on the air how did you get that on like
Fox I mean I should preface this for
people haven't seen it it's basically
the post-apocalyptic and as far as you
know your character is the last person
on earth and doing all this crazy [ __ ]
that you would do when you will by
yourself how did you jeez I tell you I'm
up with it it was Chris Miller and Phil
Lord are a huge reason for it because
they're they're the guys who did the
lego movie in 21 22 Jump Street Cloudy
with a Chance of Meatballs and we've
been buddies for years so they asked me
if I wanted to write something with them
and the got there I mean they are having
such amazing success right now that that
you know people are lining up to work
with them so so I just got in at the
right time and we all came up with this
idea together how long did it take you
to get to that cuz he was just probably
like I where'd you grow up what was your
childhood like and they try to mine that
type of thing like how do you go from
the usual well like dude this is like
one of the most original ideas for sure
I've seen in a long time
Oh God thank you we sat around for about
three days and you know just but three
full days we brought up the last man on
earth kind of early in the process and
just went right by it I know we just it
didn't seem right to us and then we had
settled on this other show idea it was
actually it was about Val Kilmer used to
he stayed with me for a while cuz he we
became buddies through macGruber and
then he he know this was in real life
this is in real life how did he end up
staying with you he stayed with me
because he has a place in New Mexico but
but he wanted he he likes to have a
place in Malibu as well while he was
leaving this one place and wanted to
look for another place so he just needed
a place to stay for what I thought was a
couple days and he just couldn't find
the right place so it ended up being
several months so that was what we were
gonna write the show about it's gonna be
kind of a fictional I kind of partly
fact did it weird at some point we're
like well I gotta tell Val Kilmer to hey
man it's such a weird thing like it's
not use a bump it's like dude can you
hurry up and find a mansion no it was
looking Miyoshi I'll tell you it was the
best couple months of my life it was so
much fun you know he's like a member of
the family so it's it's uh he's
hilarious to like remember and he's top
secret remember that oh my god who's Doc
Holliday Wyatt Earp tombstone excuse me
oh man I study the best he's so fair
have you met him no I never met him but
I have him on your show he is so
wonderful so he stayed with you
answering those smart and yeah he was
there for three months so we were gonna
write something about that and and I
don't know for some reason we just
couldn't figure out what's the because
there were a bunch of really fun things
that happen in in real life but then it
was like what's that blend of fact and
fiction and you know what how does it so
we we were a little mixed up with that
and right as we were so they don't
really figure it out what's up so they
were probably gonna go with the comedy
thing is rather than because there's no
you can't get five years in and this guy
crashes with me and we had a great time
it's his best time of my life they
probably were going to try to go the
route that the guy was annoying you when
they would well no we were just gonna
base it on our own characters because it
was kind of like an odd couple in a way
but but but in an odd couple in which
both people are kind of the the Oscars
kind of mixtures of Oscars and Felix's
like he's he's the best but but it's you
know just there's some that actually
it's very funny because we thought about
well well he was staying with me I was
watching The Amazing Race
that was that was I was really into that
show at the time I still like it but I
just had don't watch that much anymore
but he thought I was an idiot for
watching it and then I got him hooked on
it they're hooked is the wrong word
fascinated he got fascinated so we for a
short period of time we're planning to
try to get on The Amazing Race together
that would he come we both called our
agents and they're like no way you're
doing this there's no way you still
think it would have been great yeah I
still hold out hope that that will do it
someday I had an idea a long time ago
it's good friend of mine one of the best
comedians ever saw Patrice O'Neal right
oh yeah so we were he was crashing with
me during this pilot season and we were
flipping through the channels and Judge
Judy was on and she was just sitting
there screaming and yelling and berating
people and everything it was just
[ __ ] annoying like just her whole
like I know it's almost like just
grandstanding to get ratings and I was
came up with this idea I was trying to
convince him to do it I would say listen
either you sue me or I sue you okay and
we'll pay each other and then when we
you know when the whole the dust settles
I'll just give you the money back and
you give me my money back in cash nobody
knows right and the whole thing was so
we could get on that show and then all
we would do was go on there and try to
see how mad we could make her and just
when she told us to shut up you keep
interrupting her going lady lady lady
just anything just to get into her ego
and I just felt because like so much of
it just seemed like a cartoon to me yeah
she was yelling just to yell and also
there were so many like mouth-breathing
morons that they had on the show that
she was always going to see super
intelligence so I felt if we went on
then we played the dumber we played it
yeah more her showbiz sense would kick
in like all this is comedy gold yeah and
then once we got a mad then you sort of
start insulting her and and just saying
if we could just make her lose that was
a great word were you guys at that time
we could no we made her
we weren't perfect nobody knew maybe no
I don't think so I was trying to think
you didn't do that anymore
he did a yeah cos because now the
internet they look up they find out who
you were yeah but I think they'd find
out after they aired it and then they'd
never dare it again I don't know man I
would I didn't watch the American race
but if I saw the two of you on there I
would definitely watch it they had I
have a celebrity one no [ __ ] that
Michael White was on there one so you
know that he was on there with his dad
that was one of my favorite things like
seeing him with his dad it was that
there had such a sweet relationship oh
they didn't fight or anything they
didn't really they were very supportive
of each other and and Mike was because
uh I remember everything but I remember
his his dad was not as as fast as him
but Mike was incredibly patient and they
were great it was just so much fun
watching them and I thought God I want
to go in the Amazing Race with my dad or
Val Kilmer let me ask you this with you
a nice laid-back vibe how did you first
react to New York when you went to New
York during your uh did you go to New
York first and then get on SNL or did
you have like other gigs brought you
there I went I I went there for SNL but
it wasn't my first time I was Arab I
wrote for Letterman for about got nine
months in 97-98 it was my first job ever
was the Jenny McCarthy sketch show on
MTV and then I got a chance to write at
Letterman right after that that job it
was it was terrifying like he's in
Letterman's my you know him yeah that
kind of Martin that guy still has like
SNL Gary vibe that was you know the
Peter Sellers I was there my for you
know like Letterman is is one of my my
you know one of the things that really
shaped my comedy you know and and and so
to work at that show was really crazy
was terrifying and I sucked at it we do
monologues are you writing sketch pieces
I was doing sketch pieces and and you
know writing toptenz and stuff like that
and it was it was such an honor to be
there but like I wish that I
had a little more experience before I
went there and it was so tough because
then these guys
I was probably 27 at the time yeah and
then the guys who came in right after me
were coming straight from college I
think there were 22 and they were doing
amazingly well there and and it was
super easy for them their first job at a
school and they were the guys who went
on to create How I Met Your Mother
trial carbine some people just they're
born with that gift to be able I I can't
I just suck at that I tried writing for
the SBS a couple years in a row and I
was just I just never wrote like that
did you have to do the pattern stuff I
when they go up to the you know to
announce Awards no get it oh that's the
worst
louis c.k talked about that on on on
Opie and Anthony we're saying that like
what the pattern that they come up with
believe it not that's the best you can
do you only see something cute you do it
you get in you get out and that's it I
never had to do that I had to do like
monologue jokes but like I just never
had written from that like like okay
bill we need some volleyball jokes and
you just sitting there going alright
volleyball he's just staring at that
blank page I just felt like I was back
in high school again it's just I've just
always written it from like you know
that bugs me I'm gonna talk about that
but now all of a sudden you're like
writing for somebody else so like you
know it's a good job but it's not really
in his style yeah it's too mean-spirited
I got a lot of that and like it was
still a great experience but just trying
to to do like I had already respect
their writers but to actually had have
had a couple of those jobs it was uh I
quickly realizes like this this is not
for me yeah
this is not something when you get an
idea do you write it down on like I used
to have these notepads and would is that
how do you remember your IDs that's how
ideas that's how I used to do it I used
to back in the day I was working in a
dental office with my dad and these
little manila envelopes said it you'd
put the the x-rays in after I take an
x-ray pour up a model of some [ __ ] right
and I used to just write them down
I used to write and but I would be
writing out the whole idea yeah you know
and hoping that you know didn't want to
lose any of
yeah and then I try to transfer it to a
notebook and then just became those
little manila things then if it just
can't just became like one word and now
it's just like occasionally I'll type it
into my phone yeah but I kind of just I
don't know I just see something go I'm
talking about that and then if I
remember I go onstage and I talk about
it and if I forget oh my god I just I
let it go I want to look at my I know it
I think I have like a little section in
my phone oh I got I got all kinds of
[ __ ] in here let me see what you got
okay no I just write one word no I wrote
bad jokes these are I wanted to remember
bad jokes oh these are so here I'll
throw a couple of these out I have a
series of me and my buddy have these
dumb who's on first type jokes but they
involve like for instance a Vanagon if I
see a Vanagon
I say oh my god look I used to have a
Vanagon
wait is that end wait I used to have a
Vanagon this is already awful this is
why it's in the bad joke section I used
a Vanagon oh that's crazy I don't
remember you having a van in the first
place no I never had a van but you said
you had a Vanagon
no I yes but you never had a van in the
first place
you'd never know it's it's really bad so
then I wrote down different cardigan we
could do with toboggan okay that's
horrible then I have no matter what
speed you're going you're always going
this fast when you're going through an
airport terminal velocity that's not
even show this is yeah I said birdseed
it's so overrated know what I think
about birdseed it's for the birds
you know what's this is mining I do
stand-up
I could write oh yeah I think I have
down here insistence I know the car
should be in the back laughing at this
this is the worst
it says Rakata be kidding me like
ricotta cheese yeah
I'd like this one's great oh here are
two that are great
I like Dublin but there's one place I
like slightly more tripling boom Baz
brick yeah I go to this great dive bar
Greg Louganis is there all the time okay
I actually like that one hi those are
the kind of jokes I send to my wife just
to annoy her I Center one the other day
I said what did the fashionista say to
her son I'm proud of you like prada
shoes just to watch your [ __ ] groan
and send these things back to her if ik
but I just I don't think any of these
are good that's there do you know
there's supposed to be Bette but I don't
have a thing in here that says good
jokes
these are Jessie I only like remembering
the bad ones I got in my phone right
here I have I don't Kanye West and then
it says dictator even I as a white dude
have unfulfilled dreams as a dictator I
don't know what that means
and then the cruise ships cruise ships
know there's this thing that I'm doing
that if I took over the world my ethnic
cleansing would be sinking cruise ships
so it wouldn't be race a religious but
it would be all be based on people carry
they're killing people who are dumb
enough to think going on a cruise is a
good idea so that's something that I'm
working there is like there's you know
the Norwalk virus that kind of takes
care of some of that happen I'm gonna
ask you doing the last man on earth with
a creating that thing were you guys any
there's got to be some somebody and
there's got to be a little bit of a
conspiracy theorist or somebody paying
attention to the fearful talks about
global warming you see this [ __ ] on the
internet saying California is gonna be
out of water in a year and you're just
like why am I still paying my mortgage
yeah yeah yeah I get terrified by that
stuff that the new one I've always been
scared of earthquakes but the one that I
keep hearing about is like super volcano
stuff I think we've heard of that one
what's that
apparently there are a couple J Ganic
volcanoes that blow every couple hundred
years and and there's one somewhere
close to us that's that's way overdue
and so we're worried about these
earthquakes but there's going to be a
super volcano that's going
love it I just can't wrap my head around
that that could ever happen to me I just
feel like this you're gonna be in France
at that time I know you're gonna be in
France is you're gonna be safe why cuz I
just know you're gonna survive this how
do you know I'm gonna be in French cuz I
just have this feeling you don't have
the shining you know I'll tell you how
[ __ ] up that is I was actually talking
to my wife about an exit strategy out of
this business
because nobody seems to ever work on it
yeah like how you gonna get out of it
gracefully yeah how you gonna walk oh
like the way Seinfeld did and I say he's
out of the business but the way he had
that great show [ __ ] killed my guy
what do you do now maybe do some
stand-up yeah he just chilled until he
came up with the next idea the the
comedians and cars things like or like
Johnny Carson or Flip Wilson you get
your money like that's the hardcore one
I'm Marvin Hagler yeah you know really I
didn't beat Sugar Ray Leonard go [ __ ]
yourselves and he moves to Italy it
starts making like macGruber type movies
over there so I was thinking I'm 23
years and I'm 46 gonna be 47 in another
23 years I'll be 69 70 I'm thinking
that's a good possibly time to just walk
and 70 and 70 I either walk and I either
it's either I'm gonna buy a place in
Paris sell all my [ __ ] live there and
finally become bilingual right before I
croak or Alabama I said I'm not joking
even why Alabama I like it there I just
I like it I actually loved the South I
liked Wyoming all those [ __ ] States
everybody shits on I love them
no oh my god I know I just never felt I
do have all of those places that's not
sure I drove through Alabama but it was
late at night I was driving from New
Orleans to into Texas and and so I don't
know Alabama too well but god I love
Florida I Love New Orleans no I was
going from New Orleans excuse me for
Orleans yeah so I didn't want to be yeah
the road kinda no I made it I figured
out the absolute actually you would not
go through Alabama I'm sorry
we're we're in Alabama do you think you
would wind up like Tuscaloosa Oh College
yeah I would death for Alabama is right
yeah I would make a decision if I was
going to be an Auburn or Alabama fan and
at this point just because I've been
into LSU like I just got into him you
know watching that crazy coach there
it's just so much fun rooting against
Alabama and also like I mean people know
I'm [ __ ] around but like I had like
this this just based on nothing like
sort of phony hatred for Alabama I don't
like the the Crimson Tide's yeah
whenever they have a big game
I always write Alabama the dream ends
tonight cuz like their dreams always win
the championship it's just stupid and
then I mean really annoys people so yeah
I think I would go maybe I'd be an
Auburn fan but I would have to live up
in Crimson Tide country because it'd be
no fun to be an Auburn fan around a
bunch of urban face this is a stand-up
comic in me like yeah where's the fun in
that
let's go on annoy people and I think
it's you know it's natural and you know
I'm not trying to offend Crimson Tide
fans
either but like if they're just such a
powerhouse you always got a unless you
are born into that you have to it's kind
of like rooting against the Yankees the
Patriots you know I'm a I'm an A's fan
so that you know the Yankees are a
natural enemy and I'm a I'm a Bruins fan
I went to UCLA and and so I get you know
I gotta be against Alabama they're just
you know they're they're so good they're
too good ya know that's I mean it's
actually I guess you shouldn't get mad
it's it's a those my Bruins are coming
they're coming
oh yeah and what football yeah oh yeah
how'd you guys do last year I was on the
road we did all right we did pretty well
we were like ten and three I think
yeah yeah right you guys were like
flatline in there for a good ten I mean
we have a you know there we had a couple
we had some tight games in the beginning
then we really started getting it
together and then we had a couple tricky
ones against you know organs so good and
that was that was a tough one
those guys with their stupid uniforms
they're ruining football because the
uniforms are bad yeah it's because
everybody's
now trying to come up with a cool
uniform and they're just not able to
pull it off like they're they have
Fonzie everybody else needs to just
[ __ ] be plot speed how do you feel
about is at Eastern Washington that has
or like Boise State through the color
the blue turf created they have the blue
and Eastern Washington has that crazy
red
I think it's desperate moves by schools
that want to get noticed but it worked
because now Boise is actually becoming
somewhat of a powerhouse I mean I don't
know they kind of have the up and down
but I also think that once they limited
the amount of scholarships all of a
sudden you know Appalachian State Beach
Michigan that would never happen yeah
back in the day so I don't know but I
you know what I realized with my a DD I
never got around to to coming up with
the the last man on earth when so so
yeah so we were mad with the Val Kilmer
thanks sorry oh my god no that's I did
that's a that's a good memory right
there no I do know it is it's it's I
read all the tweets when people [ __ ] on
me so I have their criticisms like in my
head they're not necessary bad like dude
he was [ __ ] about ready to say the
thing and then you interrupted so no
this is the most boring part of it we
did so we were we just had all these
lingering questions and we were about to
go and and then I would be left to kind
of figure out a route to this Val and
we'll show and then we just on the way
out Chris Miller is getting his jacket
on and then I just said what let's look
at this last man on earth thing one more
time and we just something a tiny
adjustment was made and and it just all
started pouring out so it was you know
we got really excited about it we never
thought that it would be a show for Fox
it definitely is weird as we were
thinking it up it seemed like it was way
more of a cable type AMC FXX whatever
they got now so we pitched it to you
know a bunch of a bunch of people half
of them cable half of them network and
we really were just doing what was the
resemblance hitches as a as a courtesy
because we thought never would any of
them
would be interested the response was
very good it was you know we had a lot
of opportunities and but you know you go
in there and you're partnered up with
the studio which was xx and and they
kind of help you decide where to do it
and they they Fox was was very
interested and and you know they they
have a lot of history xx and and Fox
obviously so so would you know was
decided that that was where would try to
do and I gotta be honest I was a little
nervous at first cuz yeah I like to
swear and I like what dirty situations I
was gonna say like when you guys were
pitching that did you guys pitch the
margarita pool and the toilet pool and
didn't we or did you come up with that
afterwards that was part of writing the
the pilot that was part of writing the
pilot that it was basically just the
storyline of this guy's all alone
doesn't know what to do and eventually
all he's hoping for is is you know to
see any other human and then finally
another human comes into the picture and
they just don't don't get along at all
and now you finally meet a woman you
think and then it just becomes this you
know played by the great Kristen Schaal
she's so unbelievable on that and I'm
psyched as a comedian to see another
comic you know not only get a you know
she's killing it on the act I think yes
there is sort of a stereotype you know
sometimes about the comedian's act or
whatever so she's doing us all a huge
favor what he's great she in the ones
that did that haven't been aired yet
she's even she like she's asked to do a
lot of because she you know she played
she's so funny and and and you know has
always very easily accessed that but but
this is like she is asked to do some
very tough things where she's like still
supposed to be this fun crazy character
we've created but also do like some kind
of emotional things yeah just perfect at
it she says she's a great actress so I
have to be able to see that your your
relationship is driving me nuts on the
show I'm like yelling at the TV going
just dump er just you can't let her move
in and I'm just why
you're getting sucked into this
relationship and like I would just feel
like it's been enough to be alone
there's got to be somebody else out
there and like as I said if she moves in
with you just go steal another house
down the street
just grab your [ __ ] and go down there
and I do like I can't tell you enough
about that I just love like all this
[ __ ] you were doing when you will buy
yourself like driving your truck into
stuff and bowling balls into fish tanks
it's just like I mean I would do that
but I always like yeah that's that I
would do that too that's what you know
we would just think up things that we
would actually do ourselves yeah find a
firework store and just just come up
with you you turn into like an eight
year old yeah but what I liked with
what's her cat the Carol character
Kristin shells character how she is she
still had morals so it was annoying and
nagging as she is like there's something
that you still have at the core her
she's like a really good person oh yeah
she's great she's she's like you know
that's the the thing is that because I'm
the last man on earth and we have to
start on me we have to kind of create
this this sympathetic character but as
the show goes on you realize like she's
the she's the real good person here and
and I'm like and so your your your
allegiances are constantly shifting so
we're trying to you know we're trying to
walk that tightrope and I don't know if
I've gotten too far away from it because
because we don't want people to hate me
forever but but I now do you know your
character salera you couldn't know you
know you saw you had your morals is when
you didn't leave Todd in the desert
which is my the way you guys shot that
were you like you know I'm not gonna try
to get whatever you know we've already
shown if people haven't seen it they've
shame on you you should have seen it you
got to stay up to date or you're gonna
get spoilers released exactly exactly
well how you just drop them off and I
just love the look on his face where
he's such a good guy it doesn't register
that you would leave him out there and
he's in his sizes white middle of
nowhere like three-hour drive he's gonna
die
and you're just driving away and then
you have to scream and like I can't do
this this is morally wrong you keep
backing up and then go no [ __ ] it
yeah I'm brewing I'm totally butchering
this the way you guys shot that thing oh
my god that was a Peter Atencio the guy
who
who directs all the key & peele stuff he
did that oh wow yeah I know him um you
would like him you would like I don't
know if I ever met him
I'm the worst dude like I I i act when
they let me so a couple times a years
I'll get a gig and I'll meet all these
cool people and then I'm just back out
on the road doing my doing my stupid
little at Howard how many days would you
say you're on the road no no no no I
love it
I absolutely [ __ ] love it I love
being a comic so I don't know at least
at least half the year maybe not maybe
not as not but it's not bad I mean every
other week I work I mean that's a joke
compared to back in the day when I had a
job and to be there every [ __ ] Monday
through Friday yeah and it's just like I
mean no wonder people like like there's
no reason the only reason we for me to
become an alcoholic is just the downtime
just out of boredom which is a pathetic
reason to keep you busy that's a
pathetic reason to be an alcoholic but
like anybody who's in the working world
I totally get it
yeah it's just like it's just the
build-up the [ __ ]
I used my hooker and now it's the same
deal it was like it would either be when
I'm really really stressed I would smoke
or when I'm just really bored so I had
to be kind of busy but unstressed to not
smoke I just remember by like Tuesday I
always said Tuesday dragged worse than
Monday Monday was just he was so
bleary-eyed from the weekend before you
knew what the Roach coach showed up or
was lunchtime but like Tuesday was just
like that's when reality setting you
didn't drink the night before you
[ __ ] sober and you just sitting there
going oh this is this is it this is what
I'm working tired from Monday but you
still have enough of the rest of the
week that it sucks
you're not like once you get to
Wednesday it's like okay only two more
days it's close a and Wednesday were the
worst for me and then Thursday you got
your check and you got hope it was the
first time you had hope and then Friday
felt like the last day of school and
yeah then I just remember like literally
running out of I worked in this
warehouse which was a great job
unloading trucks and [ __ ] but I just
never running out of there and and just
the weekend would go by in two seconds
by Monday I was [ __ ] broke I'd like
no I know overhead or anything and I
would come in
would just be absolutely broke and so
Monday though I would make the people
laugh telling my stories from the
weekend that's how I'd get to lunch and
then I just limped through but never
then Tuesday Wednesday which would just
[ __ ] kill me so whatever I'm just
getting back to the point if you have a
drinking problem and you actually have a
job I completely understand it
advocating alcoholism so I don't have a
drinking problem I drink I fall down
don't know I drink I get drunk I fall
down not a problem no problem there you
go I'm gonna write that in my phone hey
if you are into booze you know there's a
really good whiskey somebody turned me
on to called alibi
you try it I've never tried it oh my god
I love I'm a whiskey person whiskey and
bourbon not scotch it's not scotch
whiskey right I don't even know all I
know is couple Ice Cube's it's alibi it
sounds like it wouldn't be Scotch alibi
it sounds like it yeah so we're stuff I
like it's the perfect time yeah if you
just want to have a couple before you go
to bed it's like thirty bucks for a
bottle just tear through this thing
you're not worried you buy actually buy
something nice you got to have like the
hope that abhi is this the right moment
to open that bottle and you know don't
put any don't put any [ __ ] ice cubes
in there this is just I don't know
everybody's drinking makers every
Daenerys Jack or whatever was just
something different somebody got me and
I got a tour coming up going through the
South with some buddies of mine and
we're gonna be on a bus and I'm gonna
think of uh stocking it up and oh here
we got my [ __ ] myself out if the makers
of alibi would like to send us some
whiskey we'll talk about it on all our
podcasts there we go that's that'll be
like the end of me so alright I'm
jumping all over the place I gotta go
macGruber here okay one of the funniest
[ __ ] movies of the last four or five
years absolutely love that Paul virzi
the buddy of mine who headliner but
everyone said well come around open for
me
he he's the one who told me he said dude
he goes you got to see this movie he
went to go see with his two brothers and
he said he was like punching one of them
and [ __ ] grabbing the other one just
watching it and that's so cool oh my god
dude I was watching clips of it this
morning I
I finally uh you know I was so busy I
had to watch refresh my memory and all
that stuff cuz I forget movies a second
Psalm it just like I I don't know I'm
gonna rule in this movie too but just
how you put together the whole team what
it is I grew up on those movies and they
weren't trying to be funny it was
serious roughly the same age and I the
movies that we were were like this was
our love letter to those movies that are
the same movies that I watched uncommon
valor right you know die hard obviously
and you know Lethal Weapon all those
that the 80s was just the Golden Age of
those and they just they just kept
coming out with a guy there was there
was Stallone and then Schwarzenegger and
then I want then and what's-his-face was
in there I know Mel Gibson L know Mel
Gibson was in there what's this guy the
guy with the red beard Chuck Norris Oh
Chuck Norris the guy with the red beard
kicked me across the room uh Delta Force
right Delta Force yeah missing in action
trilogy
yeah with Tex Cobb I watched all of
those then there was a Jean Claude Van
Damme and before him I was he before uh
Steven Seagal Steven Seagal I think I
always have the two of those guys lump
together ah no disrespect oh yeah yeah
Judah will break down all of those
movies and he'll have you wanting to go
I mean once house go was that one way he
was uh they can't break in everybody's
arms and stuff like and he goes he was
just like marked for death he's a great
movie I go what was that one about he
goes that was basically Steven Seagal
beats up Jamaica and he introduced and
he gives incredi goes he introduced the
breaking of bones into martial arts
movies well before was like people got
knocked out they got kicked they got
thrown across the [ __ ] room they went
through walled but he actually like I
swear to god that movie has like so many
like Joe Theismann like bone breaking
you got to like look away but so I got
to ask you being a fan Roadhouse also it
was a big one for us I was just gonna
ask you well if that beginning scene has
to be an homage to use that when you're
in your Miata and you put your stereo in
and they show you putting the air your
glasses on it was that
Lauren house has that classic scene
where Swayze gets in the car and they're
showing the couch guys I done and then
they shown his car at one point like
this showing all this cool [ __ ] about
him at one point he takes out a key
sliding a cassette tape into his oh my
god I don't you know what I
I have probably only seen Roadhouse once
maybe twice and it was none of it was
researched for the show okay
so I these were all just you know so if
if it was an unconscious homage if it
was any kind of homage I mean definitely
you know the those are the movies we
loved but but as with everything I
usually my research consists of my
tattered memories that remember you know
I hold the whole philosophy behind
Roadhouse where it was just like this
guy had this bar and he just couldn't
keep it under control and like Swayze's
like this like almost like a national
headlining comic but like he's a bouncer
like we got to get this guy in here to
start beating the [ __ ] out of the worst
bro it's like why don't you just call
the cops yeah you don't get a metal
detector maybe maybe not over serve
people like why don't we start with the
basics before you have to bring in like
like this ringer to come in but I want
to watch Roadhouse again now now I'm
excited to see it again ah dude it's
it's one of the it's just a grant where
I think what the throat rip didn't
didn't they rip somebody's throat out in
roadhouse
pretty sure that's I haven't seen in a
while
I just member sways and leaning against
the wall and the music was on and ran
rather than nodding his head down on the
beat he was doing this thing where he's
nodding it up which made it look even
more as I was like he was saying hello
to somebody across the bar it was just
it was this so I don't know the guy's
dead I shouldn't be [ __ ] on his
movies but I mean it's just it's I feel
like you're glorifying them I don't it I
mean it's it's I love that movie we went
too far in the other direction though
because now I feel like every guy in so
many of those movies hey you know he
doesn't have express himself he's
awkward he's got his hoodie
and I just you know the whole my wife
calls it the man boy you know the guy
who's 35 but acts like he's on like a
first date like that whole thing yeah I
just feel like that is uh was sort of
the overt that like that's the price
we're paying for all of those you know
missing in action movies like now it's
going to go completely the other
direction
yeah so I'm trying to think how the hell
they're gonna mock those like the next
generation of people mocking like those
those types of movies that everybody
grew up on but uh but I asked people on
Twitter to send me some questions for
you and one of the overwhelming ones was
is there you know is there gonna be the
macGruber part - well we've that's
that's the plan we've written about 2/3
of an outline we a very in-depth outline
and we really like the stuff that's in
there we have to figure out a you know
it's more just scheduling stuff but like
we've been working on the last man on
earth me and John Solomon are - two of
the trio and then your ma Taccone he's
working on a movie right now so it'll be
a while we're gonna try to start writing
how long does it take you a week aresome
how long does it take to shoot it
macGruber was like 27 days 27 workdays
so was weeks or something I just love
when you blow up your whole crew like
what do you about you is you go with the
real reaction like you do but for a
different thing
like like if you blew up your friends
you just dropped you knees but you go
like oh no no no like like a cat was
peeing on something in your house that
you're gonna vine or wear that night
that's [ __ ] killed me all of that
like urea and like your facial
expressions and all that type of [ __ ]
well by the way I don't even know if
we've we have some information that
there are a couple different people who
might be willing to to let us make the
movie so so but you know we won't know
until we actually like send in a script
how did you come up with the salary bit
in macGruber I need a distraction like
you just go like all right I'm gonna get
butt ass naked and stick a piece of
celery between my ass
I think we were just watching a but I
know that your man and John watched a
bunch of MacGyver's and while we were
writing and you know some one of us
would be writing and they'd be watching
stuff and writing also and and they saw
something in there where he he had had
this table of things laid out and made
it seem like he was about to use every
element of that to cook up some kind of
solution trap [ __ ] yeah and one of the
things on there was a carrot he said it
alright let's see what we got here and
then you cut to him eating the carrot
just like he was hungry it's so for some
reason it came from that and originally
it was gonna be a carrot and then we
thought like oh well that battle seemed
it already wasn't you know it was our
own disgusting take on on that and
didn't really have anything you know
obviously you just stripped down to
nothing behind something you grabbed
your junk and you stick celery and you
just walk out in front of a camera crew
that's when people go like oh yeah you
know like doing stand-up oh my god they
like takes so much courage it's like
it's when I walk out clothes and if it
goes wrong I blame the crowd I mean it's
it's easy like you got a worse thing as
my mom was there that day and not that
wasn't even the worst thing but my mom
was there so we're at this warehouse and
I looked you know I had done a couple
takes and I look over and there's my mom
and she had two friends with her so
they're the friends were you know my mom
has kind of a pasted on smile like
that's my son that's he's doing this is
he's getting paid for this that's comedy
it's kind of $12,000 I made $12,000 from
Gerber Jesus Christ
and then her friends were just aghast
they they've these all Northern
California nice yeah nice gentle
wonderful people and I think they're
they're you know least least they
weren't there on the days when you were
down on your knees going I will suck you
back that would have been I will let you
[ __ ] me my mom lost friend that's
because my mom is the most supportive
person in the world and she's she
brought several friends she would just
my mom probably saw my macGruber 20
times in the theater just so she could
bring two
friends and some of them are no longer
her friends because of that movie really
uh Kristen Wiig who's one of the
funniest people ever uh playing your
idea love interest and I loved it the
keyboard so my favorite thing is when
she whispered I love you but like your
sex seems what I mean thank God your mom
didn't show up that day when you met Hey
oh hey like she's Kristen it was such a
trooper because why do you guys like I
was thinking you could probably get like
0.8 seconds before you start laughing I
kinda take you to shoot that it thank
you very using the term shoot it was it
was like probably two hours in this
upstairs bedroom so it's we're in
Albuquerque in the the middle of the
summer it's already super hot everywhere
you have these these lights burn and you
you know and and so this room is just an
oven and I am I am a sweater if I get to
a certain point I'm just I start
sweating his fake [ __ ] yes white oh
my god like about four thrusts in and I
just started pelting her with with like
huge drops of sweat there's hair all
over her she's it was her birthday - so
she was it was just the worst birthday
of all time oh my god but they're they
gave her a very special treat they
because we're in Albuquerque so they
they like hooked her up with this
special room in Santa Fe where she could
go and shower and get massages and get
the mousse wet experience out of her
head did you uh did you like what sort
of mindset because I was you know I'm I
try to get these acting gigs or what
every once in a while and like my big
thing is like having to you know the big
thing that turning point for me when I
finally actually started getting jobs to
not be self-conscious like something
like you you seem the quiet reserved
kind of person but like the characters
you play and how hard you commit to them
like will you like mint I'm just asking
you like as a you know potential actor
tat to a great actor like where do you
go like me mentally but would you just
walk in like I [ __ ] this I gotta just I
got a
do you have to psych yourself up to go
100% he one of those people like alright
I'm just disappointed it's not really
easy to fully commit it's it's really
hard when you when you think something
is is not good to do that you have any
examples early on without outing anybody
that wrote something I know you you seem
like you don't want to [ __ ] on anybody
so just different sketches that at SNL
you know whereas sometimes you would be
asked to do somebody else's sketch in
your word you know you have no say in it
or sometimes you would write your own
little turd and and like you get out
there and you go oh this is this is not
good how does that work how does it work
I will say oh sorry it makes it through
the gauntlet of all those people trying
to get a sketch on yeah it makes it past
Lauren it makes it past think they do it
like a little run through right
everybody's thinking it's funny now when
it goes out there is it just dies is it
well I mean it's the funny thing is like
you you like at The Groundlings we we do
shows that are there I'm not there
anymore but but when we when you sign up
to do a show you're doing the same show
for about three months you know you have
this process where you're getting the
show together and once you lock in the
show it's the same show you know for for
heads you know when one show on Friday
two shows Saturday night that same show
up for three months and there are nights
when everything kills in there are
nights that stuff just totally falls
flat so you just realize oh geez it's
it's the audience it can be anything so
at SNL you're just you know some nights
some nights it's definitely the material
some nights you just have an audience
that might be slightly older or slightly
younger you know you just you never know
so sometimes you get really lucky and
sometimes you get really unlucky most
the time you know the stuff will get the
the the shake that it deserves but but
not always and what was your game plan
if you're doing this okay
you're you're on live television you're
doing a sketch and it bombs it's
starting to bomb it's starting to bomb
you feel it bombing and then do you have
like a thing where you're like you know
whatever plow through this thing or I'm
going to commit even harder or I'm gonna
try to make the other person in the
scene laugh or just some some way to try
to pull some sort of victory out of it
or do you just try to get through it and
pretend it never happened
I'm pretty good about maintaining the
level of commitment I'll never try to
laugh that's that's a little bit of a
cheat
yeah I never Ser was somebody break
character yeah yeah I mean it's I've
kind of go into hyper focus it's not
even that I don't like sometimes I think
stuffs really funny and I just I just am
concentrating on not screwing up
but like it's we did it bill Bill Hader
and I did this sketch with Josh Brolin
called fart face he just talked about it
on it this I wish you were in the
audience that night because people hated
it I mean it was it was how can you hate
fart face I know right if and it wasn't
just that it's not like but it wasn't
gratuitous use of the it was semi
gratuitous use of the term fart face but
it was a business setting and he's too
very committed this emotional scene
between two guys one of them's calling
the other person a fart face and it's
hard to describe we did it at the dress
rehearsal show - complete silence it was
almost it was almost so silent that it
was a vacuum we almost opened up a you
know some kind of import hoard yeah so
you know we thought oh that's crazy I
liked it I don't know I don't know why
that audience didn't like it but you
know well David our best gave it our
best try anyway we go up you know it
what happens is you finished the dress
rehearsal show you wait about a half
hour then you go in to find out the
pieces that are selected now this was
the night it was during that 2008
election cycle and Sarah Palin was
actually there that night she Tina had
already been doing herself
sarah palin this was i believe the night
that Sarah Palin herself actually came
on to so this was a big deal of a show
for a finale I think it ended up being
the most-watched SNL in years you know
years and years anyway we go in there
and we see that fartface is somehow in
the show it made it into the show you I
mean there were no laughs at all so it
was I still you know a a real testament
to Lauren cuz it was you know he thought
he thought it was funny I guess
no I say Lauren goes through and he does
different notes during the during the
you know it's like oh it's too you know
there was a there was this maybe you try
to speed up this during this and it goes
to read sketch and I just remember him
coming to to ours and he says there's a
boom shadow on fart face he goes on to
the next thing so we go out there and it
was just like we remembered the
experience of no no laughter at all so
you're going on now built I didn't
remember this but Bill told this on on
Letterman I think he said that Josh
Brolin came out and we were all sitting
there was like we were going into battle
and Josh Brolin says all right let's go
shut these [ __ ] up something
like that something like that and and it
was and we did we did we went out there
but we gave it our all but you know all
three of us but it was I watched it
because when I heard Bill talk about it
I thought I got I want to watch this
again we watched it and and I still
stand by that sketch it's funny I don't
know what I don't know we've really
committed to it it's stupid for sure
right but I'd you know I don't know I
did you know some things you just that's
there's no way if I went out there if I
was with two other people and I'm doing
something like fart face and it's
bombing I think I would start laughing I
would like not laughing like it would
just make me want
commit harder to it and maybe stress
fart face so make a weird face that
somebody just something like I got this
weird thing where I kind of enjoy like
bombing a little bit yeah I'm not if I'm
really like if I really believe in
something if I really think of jokes
good in a not laugh and then that gets
frustrating but like if I still know I'm
being funny but it's bombing that's one
of my favorite things I did a run
through one time for this you know yet
another failed pilot and they once said
they wanted something edgy so we went
super edgy I guess it was way beyond
what the [ __ ] they thought it was going
to be so we start doing it the runs
through in front of the network guys you
know they come in it feels like the AC
has been [ __ ] turned down even lower
and they come in and just the first
thing dies the second thing dies next
thing and all of a sudden these actors
I'm working with got this looks on their
faces and then that became my motivation
that became my entertainment was doing
the scene and then passing other actors
and they was shooting me looks like
going oh my god this is bombing and it
just became my entertainment it was one
mother my favorite run-throughs I ever
did do when I tell you from the
beginning to the end it was 22 minutes
of silence like we think started I've
been there yeah it started off with that
why am I telling us that you don't know
what he's like they literally it started
off with the the guy playing my friend a
homeless guy comes up to us who they
later said was way too homeless looking
way too dirty way to fidelity he asks
for money and I'm the liberal so I go to
digging in my pocket to do it to give
them the money and my brother who's in a
wheelchair grabs like some scoop of ice
cream calls him a scumbag and flips it
in his face and it totally like caught
his beard and like ended up in his hair
and I remember hearing like an audible
gasp from the net were there oh like it
was horrible and it just immediately
became as I got oh here we go we got one
more scene if we don't get him in the
next scene this thing is good this is a
runaway train and dude like we [ __ ]
bomb so bad and I remember afterwards
drinking with this guy and we were both
back at the hotel just laughing going
I'm getting fired now I'm getting fired
or whatever nothing I don't know well
stage was that was that like the early
run-through of the show was that the
final no no this was
we were getting ready to shoot the pilot
okay and we were coming up on it and I
forget the name of the director but he
was rehearsing the hell out of it so we
were all like I remember the night when
we shot it you know toned everything
down but like this guy back rehearse
does so much I was like this is like
maniacal man this is crazy but I just
remember the night when we finally went
to shoot it there was only a couple of
pickups so I totally understood the
method a method of his madness I just
needed to do one episode with them yeah
well unfortunately that was the last one
because he was a great director but the
at that point it was just a run-through
so we're already in there there's nobody
in the bleachers there's no audience sis
no nothing yeah and what what's funny is
they did the first scene and usually the
writers will sort of laugh along and try
to prime oh yeah to get getter I mean go
as some people who are writers who's who
basically are only hired because they're
good luck yeah runners yeah just to get
people going but I think when they
audibly gasped and it bombed and then it
was just the sound of shoes walking on
the floor over to the fake living room
like to the next thing I think everybody
was like oh my god this you just felt it
in the air and I think even the writers
claimed they probably wanted to walk out
it was just the weirdest thing ever it
was one of my favorite things I ever got
to be in yeah that 22 minutes of just
absolute utter sighs I got a bomb I
can't even remember my end I can't even
in the end if it was even anything
clapping I just remember this one
actress face who was playing the mom she
kind of like she did a line that bombed
and then I did my line at bond it was
classic like you know sitcom movement of
actors yeah you say your thing and then
you walk out this door if somebody else
walks in you know just that sort of like
a play and I just remember her walking
past this [ __ ] look at her face like
she had just seen a ghost and I don't
know that's why I always like talking to
you guys who came up through sketch
because I'm I've always been a huge huge
fan and I just want the completely
different the isolated way so yeah I
mean at least the thing about sketch
that's really nice and reassuring is
you're
always out there with other people and
you're also usually playing in
characters so if you if you have a
reaction that's just horrible you can
blame it on the character you don't have
to blame it on yourself which is the you
know what's really tough about how you
do it it's like when you bomb it's you
know you're Bill burr is bombing they're
not liking but the thing is you don't
bomb but as it yeah yeah oh yeah I do
and I did for a long time as you bomb
though
you have the option to just pull the
ripcord and go into something else where
you guys are just like it's like you're
getting in a bobsled and you just go
down you're picking up speed going to
this brick wall and there's no brake and
you just have to slam into the thing but
you just brought up like doing character
so I wanted because we've kind of I know
you have this one was it WonderCon you
have to go to WonderCon I want to do
whenever I wanted to ask you like what
is what are your favourite characters
that what you have a favorite character
that you do favorite characters that I'd
that I knew yeah the most you to do I
love doing this character called
Hamilton from SNL I didn't do it that
many times but but the funny thing is
it's kind of this definitely a very odd
insensitive racist just a weirdo and and
it's any and what's fun to do this and
then Seth Meyers asked me to do the
character and is his rehearsal dinner
they were he asked me to give a toast as
this guy that was it's one of the most
fun things I've ever done and then Andy
samberg's wedding was like two weeks
later it so he he was at Seth's and he
said oh we gotta come do one of those
for me so I've had so much fun how do
you come up with the lunette character
and I don't have an outlet to do stuff
like that that much anymore oh my god
it's late night said SNL like you're how
do
just like they'll take the little kids
this is a comic I'm so fascinated with
their sketch guys like how you do the
thing I was watching when you were doing
the Tim Calhoun character Oh Tim Calhoun
and when you were like running for
president I watched this clip this
morning and you you were doing this
thing with your fingers when you you do
like like three with the left and then
three with the right and you were just
saying all this horribly like offensive
stuff and you were speaking and like
this whisper but like you you kind of
captured like that like I'm tell me runs
for president if they're making an
annoying gesture yeah like they'll say
oh don't do that that that seems rude
and then you can just see them like so
as they're trying to give this speech
self-conscious about what to do with
their hands like you like we're picking
up on that stuff and that's one of those
things well I gotta give the credit on
that and like that that's something I
used to do at The Groundlings and that's
that's one of the things that I used as
my audition piece because that was but
but I had written this thing and I was
can you do a little bit of Tim Calhoun I
don't put you on the spot that's the
worst rendition of that Brandon you're
gonna trade the Grand Canyon for the
Eiffel Tower and when they send us the
Eiffel Tower we're not going to give him
the Grand Canyon the woman who was our
director at The Groundlings she was the
one who told me to do something with my
hands and and even gave me these
specific instructions so I had the the
sheepish look in the the words I had
written all that but but she gave me
that which is such an important element
of it so like that's you know that's one
of the good things about sketch two is
it's you know you've got this whole team
of people around you or or helping to
make everything better I don't know why
I think I think you're one of the best
mad and I'm so I'm so happy for you that
that you own those guys like you know I
didn't even bring up like Nebraska or
all others like that's a draw
you know something did uh somebody want
an Oscar in that right it was nominated
and I have done any research in this we
did okay right
I think somebody wants something shiny
no day it was nominated for a bunch
Bruce Dern was nominated Alexander Payne
was nominated for directing it it was
the film itself was nominated June
Squibb was nominated for for Supporting
Actress it was it wasn't I still can't
believe I had to be a part of that yeah
well I've been what I've been obviously
since I've been watching you that sounds
creepy but I've been a fan of your
career but I do just seem like one of
those guys where you you actually in the
career that I love you you're like
people know you but you're not like
sucked into that uh you know
Entertainment Tonight like today coming
out of Starbucks we got Will Forte and
some hugs like you weren't in that and I
was just like watching like you said
this guy's making cool choices
everything that he makes is of quality
whether you know any huge whenever any
you know you get in a [ __ ] movie you
don't know what is gonna go up against
whether it works or not but like you
would just always get good in everything
so when this thing came out I was
thinking I'm like such an original idea
oh my god Will Forte it's gonna be this
is gonna be you know exceeded
expectations but I got to give Foxx
props because way back in the day they
did a real do you ever get a life with
Chris le oh well yes he lived at home
with his parents and he had a paper
route he was like in his 30s that was
just lived in the Attic and it was just
so [ __ ] weird and like so they do have
a history of uh oh my god doing stuff
like that many of those old but like
like I remember when Fox was was really
young and and and yeah that show kettle
life was so great the Garry Shandling
show there's shanlee show oh my god Mary
Sheldon was the one that blew up it with
children Tracey Ullman Show all those
shows word Simpsons and the Simpsons
came out of that yeah so well dude
you're they pass the baton to the right
guy man I do you have anything that you
want to promote before no ray look at
effortless tower here no I mean whatever
I just want to say thank you to Fox and
thank in Saturday Night Live two of the
great experiences of my life
all right I did you know we talked about
it up and I go back and like I you know
I'd go like god I hope you know I'll
tell little stories about Saturday Night
Live but I forget if I tell the part
which is like how appreciative I am to
what an experience it was and like you
know to Lauren none of this would be
happening if it wasn't for him so yeah
you know what a great experience well
dude you've been yeah I've just been
kiss-ass
that's the equivalent of me saying good
night at the end of a party it's still
in there well that's a man I am so
psyched that you agreed to come on the
podcast their continued success I'm
watching every episode anybody listening
if you haven't watch if you haven't been
watching last man on earth
definitely go out and try to get caught
up with it because it's really one of
the most original things that I've seen
on TV in a long time it's absolutely
hilarious
and congratulations to all your cast
members Christian Shaw January Jones Mel
Rodriguez who's crushing it and that's
it enjoy your time down at WonderCon
whatever the hell that is and I had to
run as you soon tell healthcare I said
hello
I will all right dad that's it that's
the Thursday afternoon podcast Monday
morning podcast on Friday all right go
[ __ ] yourselves
I'll talk to you on Monday